More than half the people in the world access
the internet on mobile devices instead of desktop
computers. And if you just have mobile device
you can still learn to code. In this tutorial,
you will learn about apps and resources you
can use to code on an Android device. So Heidi,
welcome to this tutorial on Deaf sad. Alright,
so this is my first time on Free Code Camp here.
So making this tutorial on how to code or
phone right so this tutorial is basically
for those that are avid system or for builds
our system and is willing to, you know,
continue no one wants to like out so they
are not in contact with your laptop or your
personal computer. And they want to just work
on go. Alright, so this is actually for you. So
this is where I am going to be looking at how are
you going to get started putting on your phone,
the tools are going to be laid on your phone
and we're gonna look at how you can actually
poor Python, you're gonna actually code in Python
on our phone. Alright, so without further ado,
let's dive into it. Okay, good. So the first
thing you're gonna be looking at is that
alright, so I have this phone is a low spec,
is it going to be able to walk for I need?
Yeah, I just want to tell you, you don't
need to jailbreak your phone. You don't
need to root your phone, you don't need to do
anything. You just use your phone of course,
I'm going to show you my phone actually. So I'm
actually good. So my phone you can see I'm using
like my spark FIFPro which is just silly gigwalk
As it's forgive XPS and downs and within.
So you can say to anyone who does no matter
even though your phone is to get around you
can see continuities and the Alton is that this is
actually supported on all the Android devices have
not used the highways Ajdabiya by us hold up,
explored more on how they can make use of iOS.
Alright, so without further ado, let's dive into
needs. Alright, so the first thing we need to look
at his own. Yeah, so before we actually dive into
it, I am precious La Jolla from Nigeria. I'm a
back end developer, I build games and application
admin spare time. Yeah, I'm an aspiring
machine learning engineer. I'm also an ad Buddhist
published, Cardinal fanatical on Free Code Camp.
So I have an article on running Python Free Code
Camp and also running a lot of a fake account.
On your phone. I mean, sorry, I can so
without actually any further delay, just
type into it. Alright, so it's a difficult hub,
you can just visit the CCO club, you want to learn
to just read and learn since you want to. So let's
get right into it. Is it possible to code or for?
Sorry, is it possible to code on an Android phone?
Alright, so yes, you can see the answer is
what Yes, you can do programming in phone,
you just need to install some app, which lets you
do so you can also try the online compiler from
Google Play Store as it supersedes the C++.
So this iterator first we're going to be
looking at his work with online compilers.
So let's go and search for like compilers.
Like compilers. So we add these. This is a C
or like compiler. Yeah, I don't know how to
write C, I don't write C programming
language point. This is the C compiler
where you can actually just run your C, C code
here you can see the I suppose it's a lowered?
Okay, so this is actually the one we we
actually work with, I think is this ID
or ID one.com. Is chido.com. So let's go ahead and
check this out. So we were on user ID one.com. You
can see this as a Java server, I think we should
be able to change our programming language.
Exactly how you can do so you can program
language, two to three beats Python 2.3.
So embarrassed with poetry Akash baby to go
ahead and do the small town print. Sorry.
What I was just able to run this, you should have
seen is actually running I can see the outputs.
You have to generate the hello world. So this
is how you can run your store. This is a one way
around applications. Yeah. And you're thinking
about oh, yeah, I don't want to do Python. I
want to focus on web development. I want to run
HTML CSS on my phone. Am I going to do that?
Yeah, we can go ahead and just go ahead and
search for maybe three schools. Try it. So
yeah, we tried that it offered arbitrary
schools. Yes, you can just go ahead and do
h1 Sorry. Yeah, I need dessert is about is
it Those who have told him very well like
work on your mobile phone, you need to switch like
I think extra portfolio actually worked very well.
He was gonna switch to desktop mode. Alright,
so I think he had that. So we can go ahead and
let's try and close this out. So we want to do h1
lowered so why don't close the h1 usual run this
I guess we have hello world. So this is another
way you can run your stuff you can write your CSS
also. Alright, good. And the idea of Shaunda for
this is you can use code pen. So Korpela lets
you write code to write pose and is basically
beautiful for 10 engineers, for the developers
use and write to react CSS view, and imperative
you want to do so your HTML CSS, this is the right
place where you're ready to actually dive into.
Once again, you can just go right click on start
coding, they got to be HTML, CSS, JavaScript,
we have the results page. So why right here?
It's actually what's going to be results.
So let's try and do h6. By you guys, it's auto
loads by itself. Sweet auto, you don't need to
click on the wrong button for it to load. Or we
don't need to set to it say to be dekstop mode.
They got to meet up at six, which is the smallest
of all right, beautiful. So we've actually covered
how we can run this online. Now let's
go ahead and look at how we actually
run his talks on our phone. Yeah, so let's
Alright, not that everything I just listed is
you can actually access it also, on your laptop,
if you have a laptop, you can go ahead and use the
online compiler several One, two. All right, so
I'm just recommending that for people that want
to use for using your phone can't actually what
we're trying to do. I can't wait, I use the online
compiler. Right. So we want to realize where to
open the Play Store. So this is Google Play Store.
So the first you want to do is always clear and
download an application called writer and writer.
So I am writing installed already selenium
squared, I did this because this is not going
to lead to I think I have a sword already. So
make sure you install this will Once that is
installed is going to opening up. So this is our
writer. Yeah. All right, OS takes formatting for
almost program, a programming language. Let's
see this is actually jQuery in this place.
Okay, this is jQuery. It's asked for PHP tags
for JavaScript, HTML. Right? So So you receive
copy, paste, because we have this URL path
here. We have the cell per se, C acronym.
On power to code. Plus, we have the VRP.
Corruption does everything h1 to h6, adapt
every solid html5 template, and boom, you have
this, you can go ahead and do a lot. So let's
click on the play box in this play button
right under here. flavors in case you can
see bluebird saying I'm just gonna bring
up my brush. Yeah, so this blue box here.
So you know, go ahead and click on that. So run
our code. And you also want to save your code,
per word and click on this, save
what's here. So click on that.
So what that is, as you can see, it has,
it doesn't automatically which is known
in that HTML of everywhere in our name this so at
once they say index dot HTML selector paths, or
create a new directory. So this is going to save
it and displace, can see the ads the full version,
which is known as PHP. And also you can see it
supports PHP and SQL auto completion support.
So it is your choice to even want to actually
get the full version. But the free version is
actually good to work with or slash Randy's a
reward. So we can go ahead and do they can do
we can go ahead and do Yeah, we're going
to JavaScript. So let's do scripts. Lots.
Yes. So let's get our clues. Again,
these are the closing dots body for us.
So there's closure script ourself, as it is
formatted. You can see we have a lot of vs.
array. So it's all you also add CSS, right so you
can learn it so I'm not very good at CSS and you
But can develop Polish try sorry, leads to body
bark Ron, I think is bourbon color should we read
less quite close textile, sir
because on this now you can see we have this, you
can see the table format and our our CSS force.
So you can do color should be what
whites run the cacr. So we have a case.
So go ahead and save this. Now there's our app
now, you're gonna be taking produce electronic
billboards a little, a little bit like Visual
Studio code. If you want an app developer look
like Visual Studio code, the URL to go ahead
and download this particular application hard
tray edits. So distributed says we are going
to download so you have that installed already.
So let's go ahead and open it up. Distributed
try to Gemini looks almost exactly like Visual
Studio code. It's like mix them in and
they do which has to go to your phone,
we are going to clip on XP. So you see this
video we have what is the source code can also
learn how to code that when I click on stack
space, then text editor me because we have
every time he needs to know it's gonna close
as far as as far as when I was teaching
students how to code often. Yes, you can see we
have our open file. This is a workspace here,
HTML CFF. So I'm just going to open up a file year
system open this file. So this was actually I was
actually explaining dimensions CSS to an eight
year old kid using phone because he doesn't have
a laptop. So the purpose of making all this arise.
So encourage people to actually get into tech, now
be able to just use what you have. So this is a
so I'll go ahead and just click on display boards.
So display boards here. Alright,
so click on the play button.
Now this is actually this is actually it. This
is also opposite. So if I refresh, or at least
the version later to check responsiveness, you
can open it is your device browser. So this file,
we are going to load it into the world's
developer browser. Because he said he said
it copy records by force less based on see in some
cases on worksheets, but it just based on the app
itself. So they talk so let me just
type. Sorry. Let's like try these bots.
Yeah, it's not as easy as this was designed so
we can actually assess its bots, you can make
sure you because if the up to just one was,
we used to have console. So our cause was I,
I clicked on this. So that's gonna
be legit JavaScript console for you.
So we can go ahead and do console dot log. Yes.
Alright, so you can see we have console log, yes,
I think click on the play. So you
have to click on this play button.
Okay, so click on the play button. So
we also have Suica also have console.
That error, yeah, it is going to work. Let's check
it off. Error. And let's click Complete, I can see
our error. So this is actually the server script
console. We can make use of the JavaScript console
in this case. Alright, so it's as simple.
So I recommend you using this app. Actually,
this actually saves way, as we can see from the
stock mode to form mode. So this text up module,
and is a phone module. Alright, good. So we
actually see now to run HTML, CSS or JavaScript on
a phone. Let's look at how we can actually learn
how to run Python on foot. So I wrote this article
on writing Python ofall, or accelerating Chango.
And I made use of sunsweet called python three.
So you can go over to to Freako camp or look for
PI droid. So Python is a Python. Um, it's a Python
kind of stuff that allows you to run Python on
your phone. So it's like, like is an embedded
system of bytes on our application generate
that allows you to run Python on your phone.
So this is all going to work away. So let's head
over to pray. So at the store, pi dot three So I
have it installed already. So you can
go ahead and install PI directory.
Let's open it up. So this is what we have
here. So we have a terminal acidity premium
one. So the Pima one allows you to because
of TensorFlow and what am I learning stuff?
I want to use bots economy just because of World
War Two, we have seminar we can get on point. I
don't know what. I'm sorry, I made a
mistake. So let's wait. And lo what?
We should run this unexpected word.
Unexpected word. Yeah. I don't know why this is
given. Okay. Because we are trying we actually try
to run from the terminal. Yeah. Does it actually
work? So we need to have to write our code. Yeah.
A low one. So let's run the second so we have a
new word with the F. So this is it. This is only
going to be starting our Python tutorial phone.
Right assume next time Alice died. So the last
time we lived, we actually run our Hello World
code. So which is is very good. So let's burn a
CD. So to say this, we can work under us click
on this button or area. So there's gonna click
on these, say click on save, right. So click
on internal storage, I'm gonna create a new
story J. I call this pi toots. So there's Python
storia. But our slides please for the save this is
my elbow watch that pie. So he said what a pipe
that has been done. So we've learnt how to quit an
award in Python. So let's look at all the things
so these points can accept a string. So a string
is basically is a lower digit language of sets of
characters set of alphabets. So this is a string
the string is just this will be some type. And
always know that a string is called is a quoted
either with a double quotes this or with a single
port's IDs. As you can see, I use a single port,
it doesn't matter if you're using double
quotes, or using single quotes. Alright,
so Ileana prints can also sexing integers.
So as you go, I know 2.5 Because I have five.
Yeah, so let's wait for the sides. Yeah,
they can print integer, we can also print
the ball. So bowling also played
a floating number, foot number
on the council, check the types. Let's go ahead
and check our type server sugar and blue pin type.
So if you run this, like I said, we class of
strings, right, and you know that the Alawar is
a string, like I said, it's the set of alphabets
many to the string. So we have point five,
there's going to be type O five is going to give
us a class of INTZ. In so Ns is actually integer.
So we'll go ahead and do type type of 51.6 because
it is a float. So float is a decimal number
is a decimal number. The last
one we can do is on print type
of true. Is a true? Yeah, so true is not defined
I think is Catalina see. Yep. Which is a bowl.
So a bowl is a bowling ball is just true or false.
one or zero? Yes or no. So there's a bowling,
right? So that is covered. Let's save that. So
let's create a new file, click on Replace create
a new file by clicking on New Okay, so this new
fire we're gonna we're gonna add the variables.
So what are we was able to suggest how would I
put them? I can say that like local storage is
where we can store information for
future use. Let's take a look at how
frequent comm has ever got basic logo unless
such words are the boosts in program or let's
make sure to name out research on your own.
Alright, so variables are data values can change
when the user is asked a bunch of ends of the age
variable may change during the program execution.
Yes. So that is to say, I have a variable assigned
like age equals to 18, which is already assigned,
they can decide to change the variable. It's in
the future. Like I said, I call it a local storage
that stores information for visual change
and update anytime you wanted to. Alright,
so let's get acquainted variables. So to create
a variable we don't need to pass anything there.
We just need to assign our variable name assigning
to what we want to pass it to. So I'm going to
assign X equals to five. So once I did
that, I can go ahead and do print x,
again to see if five. Why. Because x is not
equal to 5x is not equal to five, that I
that we created, maybe it's not like JavaScript.
So you have to do either late for or const. Cause
to sorry, const const IQueryable, or PHP ReFS
was assigned in the last slide. No, you just
have to give it your name on equals to assign
it to the value on a party to nowhere under Name
equals two. We code comm so I know where I'm
printing name. I can see if we could company
somewhere you can do addition or subtraction
later zoo saw equals two plus two. So those are
so so yeah, R four. Right.
So this is just variable
in, in, in Python. And a variable can either be an
integer, which is a four. So I did x equals five,
it can be an event, which is second one we put
on and it can be floats number, but annual,
so f L equals 260 1.5. And the council will be
obliged to a poorly asleep or equals to true.
So we can get on Lasu. Yeah, so I don't do
if you're not you're gonna be looking at in
the future. So we can add this. So the same way
we did on everything we're gonna do type of x,
type of x is equal to what is an integer?
Exactly. So we can also do it like that. So
variable just makes it easy for system information
and make reference to it back. Alright, so let's
go ahead and save this. And we've covered what
the variables actually is. So instead of going by
the look at itself, so we have this last Oborne
Do we go ahead and click on that? So alpha is
the select for the lesson in this severe learning
variable speed pipe. Alright, so just so you know,
our Python file is always saved as a.py extension.
Right, good. So let's want to look at is
conditional statements in Python. So we have is a
type of punishment assist statement, we're gonna
be looking at the if statement. So before Arica
See, I wrote an ash route and if so, this is
a common tip. This is your comment. So a comment
is a part of CODA does not get executed by should
run this naughty comes on in square. Because
it's a comment of committed by virtue like,
or comment this now. Nicolas is going to
be waiting. Sorry. I shall commence this.
It's going to be windy Rachel RONIS. So should
we get an error? Because I was a string.
I just wanted this and I wanted to only record
which is actually wrong. So we left square,
I just commented it so that it doesn't run our
code. So the first one, if statements so this is
just a conditional statement statement checking if
a evil thing is less than 20 I want to do this. If
my morning is a morning is enough to get a
MacBook Pro, I want you to buy it. Today's
idea so we can get on to critical morning. Equals
so right so 1000 and so if money is less than 5000
Sorry, yeah, in Python, we don't do brackets.
So it's it's also even one Lester 5000
Then we have to do this as a semicolon. Click
on enter it will auto index it for you. If it
doesn't, that means you have to specify for space
1234 ways also better it's always better to just
put your colon on edges are doing that
for you allzu friends need to save more
so that's one is I can say I need to
save my wife. Because 1000 is actually less than
5000. Alright, so eventually like changes to this.
I run this Yeah, not only do we have in this clip
because our Python is good and and Zozo Alright,
are we gonna Sorry, I'm saying. So that is our
if statement. So that's an if statement. I just
tend to suppose that you Buddhism that argue
is a more They are created equal. No, you can't
just passing by these 1000 around this cache
of need to see what because 1000 is less than
2000. It's always better to save it to a
variable and just call it anytime you need it.
So the next one I'll be looking at is if
else. So else. So now, the idea is that
if the money, we're gonna push this, okay,
if the money is less than 2000 onto the See,
need to save more else, so we have to close
this indication. Who once is else else must
be the level of the if they add the exclamation
mark again, so it says sorry, nice. Let me show
my semicolon. So the semicolon is called an
indentation. So it's great and visual force. So
the space below it, four spaces are indentation
itself. So this is 1234 is an indentation.
So it's mostly indebted for your cultural
role because of actual abuse. And I do print
Yes, Crusher, run this, and I should. Yeah,
we've not get an error because the first code
was actually true. By which it was wrong. I
say this should be given an arrow. Oh, sorry.
Okay, so let's run this. As we get narrow. I see.
It's better injected broke. So it was no well
injected. It was in that head. Alright. So let's
bet on those two these. Are you guys CBF? Yes. So
which is a buy merch book? Alright, good. Okay, so
let's buy another shirt. This is to buy my book,
because my money is actually higher than the zeros
earlier. So let us leave that. So we also asked
them to call a leaf. So this is actually like, if
the money is less than 1000 I need to say more.
LLC if the money is actually greater
than 500 I need to do this themselves. So
I guess so let's get on to that. So let's do
must be in the same level as them. So I'll leave
morning. Sorry, I'll leave money
greater than 500 Georgia prints by
HP. So I shall run this. Like I see. By HP why?
Because before so return the force that this was
in true because our mornings I totally get under
those Oh, boy did not now went to the second
statement, which is money greater than
500 which is actually true because 1500
But if this is the second one is not true, then
it's going to return the last one I should add is
zero. Yeah, make any 5000. And I run this because
it's random last one, which is the by MacBook.
Alright, so that is basically the idea of videos,
pleasure and service. So you can see this as
on select further services and condition.
So a conditioner, that right? Alright, so
that is that fellow. So we're gonna be looking at
it. Let's take a look at how we can create lists
in Python. Alrighty, so to quit to list in Python,
let's get a greeting variable called My Lists.
Sorry, my lists on the grid
lists in Python we just have to
impose to just create this brackets like I
don't know why these brackets is called I
think it's square brackets. So we just need to
create a spread bracket Guerra outsiders do up
who was going to delete this we're
gonna be able to regard a range
banana Okay, so let's close that. So
as you get on those planes, my lists
like obviously you can see
we have the list printed out
Okay, so we can actually check if this is
the least kind of system because we can type
Melissa Nancy, we are the last of these. So
this is the end of that. Okay, so while you
are trying to pass us to me it's actually got a
list. So now we get each of this list up there.
So we can go ahead and get it later somebody
buy lists and selecting the first index by zero
was equivalent to count is actually from zero so
the apple is zero represent is represented as a
zoo. Why the orange general lawn white abandoned
as Silla soup? Right that's actually are we
counting program? Okay, good. So I'm selecting
the first thing this is apples which run these
two We have an apple. So the same
way by show slave index of one
of Warren in this case, which we have an
arrange selected index of two in this case,
shoving a banana, right basically that's how its
works. And we can also do something like chain
check the lens of the least simple point lane.
Which is my least not sure this is your street.
You have got to be either straighter 123 It is
actually 0123 Right? So I didn't actually another
we can create a list ready to send con list it was
to use a list keyword. I think there's a password
double curly brace, double brackets and
Apple Apple lady soccer Zachary that arrange
for inside Ida John uses Windows on check it
so let's close this bracket. Unless brains
support this virtual run this. Like I said, we
are at least for us. Let's actually check our
confirm epitaxially at least. Okay, so let's go
ahead and we'll type right portable. Secondly,
Celestron this has to be a class of please. So
this is actually our epoch Waitlists in Python.
Right so let's say this, this is a crash course
on Python. If we need to go to the RAM Python,
just head over to the Frisco comm China go
down to the loss of six hours tutorial Python,
you can exactly what he did there you can follow
it's on your on your phone. There is no there's
no draw by there's not nothing, you can just
do exactly one. Let's see this as I'm released.
So the last thing I'm going to be
checking in is, is on functions in
our chosen knob. Indices is an apology. So we have
the space sorry to feel the space. So let's zoo
on shores in Python. The way to function in
Python, we have to use the def keyword. So
this def keyword followed by the name of our
function. Let's see a low standard brackets
see a low that pertains convenient and do
discreetly sorry, not no bright returning. So this
is a print Yes, legit ello. Much run this
here. So we have one that says I'm sorry,
Toyota 2.8% noise. So yeah, we are telling the
bracket i I think I forgot that here in the
brackets. Every function is a parentheses around
it. So let's run this again. So nothing happen.
Why because we need to return it. So let's run
through the beginning. I think this was I think
I was quoting PHP we need to return just have to
see and we'll just type it out and run this so you
can see we are led so that's where our opacity
parameter in this capacity. So we can do n Lu
sorry ello gloss space Grace lib. So we need
to specify an initial run this now should get a
little messy one required positional arguments,
which is this page right? Okay, so we need to
pass in something there. So which is inside to
see whether the passage string or same pressures
run this. Let's have a loquacious. Now look at
this, this plus plus plus plus is a little bit
stressful. There's an easy way you can do that by
just using the F string which is the instructions
to string and add a quotes in lieu. Also, if I
specify the variable which is the name like this
includes database you run this you
can see we have a lot of pressures.
We should add changes to life or you know for for
identity person there will be returned back. Yeah,
before we forget. Let's save this and I
want to show you one last thing later on
shawn.pi which are based on your last
thing let's open our file. Now this
is super fine. It is by two it's
going up So this is a widget in lists.
So let's try to look through this. So for i in
my knees so we are looking at the for loop here
for finding my list list Bruins friends,
I should run this. Likewise, we have a which has
completed at apple, orange banana. So as we create
folly in, in our in Python, they also have why
so you can see while while true brains Subscribe
Now, if you run into this coupon post, it's
actually true, there is no feedback, no tobacco
not so it's just it's one source of guidance,
experimental skips right away. So you're actually
does deep dive continue to be complete. And again,
like I said, there's a lot of Python tutorial,
because it can when you look at look at rates.
Alright, so for the last part of this Moodle
Academy, we are going to be looking at some data
science or machine learning stuff that contributes
in price. We'll see you next time. Alright, so now
let's just dive into that. So what we're gonna do
is go to sample, my gun Butte under Application,
or your app on your Android phone. So I'm going to
show you that right on an application.
But we can still do that with Python is in
sunsweet Koala TV. So this is a cubic yard
ischemia load. So let's go to open this.
So this is a simple TV application. So
we should run this now. This is going to
create a KB mobile application sample for us. So
this is just an award brought in on the screen.
Okay, sorry. So you know, my internet
connection is on so I keep saying this adds
to this it. So this returns important of fix hello
world. So there's a lot of actually samples there
you can look into we have matplotlib for for
data science or plotting data upon these to like
install the matplotlib directory, the model
the model. So let's wait for us to install.
Our data can save as installed successfully.
So let's go back with our when I run this now,
this has actually been created plot for
Sonic scrape is matplotlib. So you can
see we are running multiple ad lib on our
phone. It is actually amazing. consume
these cotton to why you want to do with
it. Thus are these features here. Right?
You can also run TensorFlow for machine learning
on your phone. Yes, but you need to get the
premium version. So that is the only disadvantage
is about that. That's it. So for Open CV and
pytorch which is actually very, very well. So we
are cycling, which you can actually use for your
machine learning. So you can great I use this for
machine learning to have this digit recognition
recognize digits to classify you to classify
digit. So this is just classification algorithm in
machine learning. So this is going to classify it
as a provision matrix. And this is everything. She
wants to look into machine learning CARSTAR with
psychically to just get something today you can
move to like TensorFlow can go to a deep learning
using pytorch or whatever you want to use.
Or the same area so if I gain I think
the beauty is simple gaming is by game.
Yeah, I think it is fullscreen. So let's
extract these celestial and this is a
Flappy Bird game due to its pi D model. Fornia.
Flappy Bird games. Let's just try this again.
Okay, so yeah, I think these are some of the
gimmies for for. Yeah, so that is actually it's
good. So you can see the car Marshal and he can do
whatever you want to do. I told you about building
Android apps on your phone to build on top of your
phone. You need to install somebody's particular
parish. I'm not gonna ministers are gonna be
showing it here. But I'm gonna check it out sweet,
nice tall sons we call Java, the Java and the
GCS and they build up so this allows us to
build Android applications on your phone can
see for lousy viewed publication, so your phone
the most popular one everyone uses is E ID. To
IDs chose for other developments allows up Android
apps. They don't have to tyrannical follow to
learn out the new picket line employee development
to occur when I studied. I needed that. I'd also
want to like code Java to learn how to do this.
Around just started sketch wait so this is just
a drag and drop stop as a logic I think yeah,
I think he got removed from play store due
to support like no fully support so you
can go ahead and let's go to Chrome development
stored on some other people website go ahead and
download sketch where I think I have sketch with
so worried Yeah, I don't have Skateway Alright, so
about that is done then let's look at how you
actually wrote some minus command food data is
actually in su Attica I think you will enjoy it
so go ahead and download samox diplomacy the man
knocks the system show up on your on your phone.
So this is just it's right here so you can run
and if you want to underneath so yeah, we have
I think we have Yeah, we have begin to yell to
insert the good package which is done by PKG
so good. I have actually run boombod So using
samox on my phone before with the VNC Viewer,
it's very well sweet do anything you can do
Metasploit I need to go install kali linux use VNC
I just want to the Tamannaah or whatever you want
to use. Then you can also use this on Linux based
system to installed node j s we finally stopped by
Todd stone will be no whales install roast just
follow the line lock installation which is going
to work on the firebox is as simple as that July
60s And last not least I'm going to be looking
at in this video is our Eclipse to the games
therefore so you want to call it game so your food
pacifically through this you can use truck up so
stock tab allows you to query to the application
or to the games asset so you have these
games so the only divided by the game that
it's kind of lonely the people on the platform
company again you can you can actually set your
friends using a link without actually compile it
as a as an application. So if you like wire and
let's test on this game you can see the amount
of people the people that have played this game
as 50,000 likes so let's play this game I
see it totally works. I think I should be
able to detach my screen a little
bit for the salute alright so this
hazard Are you not able to hear the sound or
something other than microphone right now.
A gotcha with games this exists a game created
by somebody might also go ahead I quit your game
Yeah, so there's no limit to actually what
they can do. Yes, I'm about dying and this came
actually very very early but it's Elytis just
listed ACLs just collide and placed later life
ages I see what happened. Wow. So did we
wasn't is a saint. Today just let us see.
Again photosystems in boom system. Yeah, it's
taking forever to duck and it's gonna quit again
Alright, so you can explore this truck up create
your own toilet again by just clicking on dude
Yep, so this is something game
I did for my YouTube video.
So that was actually apparently crazy new game
or it can I use templates? I've lived with the
templates edit them and make
them interesting life for years
arise so nice and solid all in this video. I'm
pleased this is my first time uploading a free
campsite and when I'm showing support by ethanol
to YouTube and no other school subscribe to my
YouTube channel. I have looked tutorials tutorials
on coding of phone like the iPhone Android seven
and if you want to put in your phone to
today as please comments section and cheese
See you next time thanks a Alright so before
actually ended this video also grow up with a
Android developer team on frequent comm by Mr. Our
Sequenza less Quincy alright. Yeah, sapling see.
I'm sorry I'm pronouncing that wrong. Yeah, so all
the way in your frequent application has actually
been created. So awesome sense. The preview mode
so I'm going to explain how this works in this
application. So basically, this is also within the
preview mode the application is still in progress.
So look I should have switched for a tone of
voice and just you know it doesn't this letter
to grid starts to get an idea daddy LPs are so
they launch make sure you subscribe to it because
the app is actually Banga. So it actually
has everything you need. So this actually
will be free could come application you So what
it does is it fetches the Newsfield from the
frequency itself. So instead of like adding also
physical card, it's called a default, you can
basically just open difficult application in
front and dive into what you want to read.
Or I saw this post by an AI iPhone at, you know,
say this is a, this is actual posts that you can
avoid. And there's also other option where you
can proclaim for offline use it. So in case you
want to read this, when you're offline, while
you're not online, you can actually bookmark it.
And those going on Bookmark the link, open this
in the browser, actually. So this is going to open
the arm in the blog post in the URL, you can see
exactly what we have there is been open there. So
the app is still in progress. So there's a lot so
calm, you can see the news to the to the abdomen.
So this line is just a path on websites where you
sign up to learn how to code for free, as it is
called Free Code Camp, where you learn how to code
for free. So you can go and just get started. Just
log in and start using your mobile app sort of you
to like, go to the websites have you done and then
or, or when you're not in a laptop on your laptop
battery's dead, like we are in Nigeria, there's no
lights levied, if I just go ahead and use your
mobile, the mobile application on your mobile
phone, I just learn on the go. So we also have
podcasts where you can listen to podcasts. You can
also download podcasts. Yeah, so this is sorting.
Yeah. So I think that's all working on the podcast
feature. Yeah. So we see, you see our progress,
History and development process until we end with
the end. So like, I should have stayed on for
you, there's gonna be out. So you saw the video,
where your life listen to radio actually don't
know this called Radio? Are you listening to
frequent COMP ON RADIO serve actually don't know.
But this is actually amusing. So you listen to the
247 Music design for coding. Okay, so this is I
think, I think this is a music design for Korea.
So if you want to call it the type of songs you
should be listening. So I think this is what it
is about. Right. Now as anomalous is a donate
button. Yeah. So every little support you give.
So FICO comm epsilon. So even though it's $5,
so that was one $1. an emoji donate is actually
very good. So let's go ahead and help apples, two
more sets, you can see the app is actually good.
So we can see our bookmark here. So sorry,
the minute if I should go ahead and like
bookmark this, I think I should be able to see
the bookmark here on your back. Alright, so the
same way, I cannot just bookmark this. Right,
so it is not yet. There. You can also search for
articles. So you can see this article here. How
to build a soccer club with real Thank you. Wow.
So these are the ones that I like about Freako
camp is that it's as a safe intensive knowledge.
I literally don't see the reason why you should go
out and buy courses where you can actually slip.
This, just a sample covers almost everything,
react and say Firebase, Fastow, Redux and Expo?
Yeah. As opposed to be composite with an interest,
basically, not as of six hours, five hours.
I don't know, this is actually an amazing start,
if you want to build this application. And in
some way, there's a lot of things you can add
JavaScript to write even good documentation
or documentation or you're contributing to open
source or you're building open source projects,
you should be able to write documentation, or
writing awkward notes. Or like, at least that
idea should be two lines of code. Don't neglect
requests, knowledge, also knowledge that you think
are not necessary, don't it? Just add everything
it's like it's possible to be added. Alright, so
yeah, exhausts being tested while you're writing a
good documentation. And yeah, everything you need
is actually this basic. It's actually this preset.
So the reason I chose finalizers for iPhone users,
iOS users, yeah, there's a way you can
actually put your phone when I was teaching
web design in school. Yeah, I actually installed
a an application for iOS, just go to app store and
search for code editor or HTML editor for Excel
for just like the stimulator on your app store,
or code editor. So you're gonna see some code. I
use IDI SMSs, or Java scripts, or hopefully you
see on our resume in Python or whatever. Coyote or
Anna Yeah, last time we talked about Pedro duty,
then we can run Python. Yeah, there's another
way you can run Python. So let's say you use
Tom ox because you know, Thomas has been breaking
down essentially, I think the is not arbitrary.
So the picket PKG is actually breaking down.
So what you're gonna do is stop by Tom Python,
I think is actually breaking down.
So let's wait for this to finish up.
Okay, as you can see now what I'm seeing, so it's
actually giving repositories on Amazon also it is
down. Yeah. So it'd be done like that too. And
I've been trying to install packages that are
like, no GS, Python with using PKG or APC stuff.
So that's why I recommend the are you actually
using this on CD is actually fixed? Yeah, so it's
fixed, don't worry, you get an update from it,
then, let's go to play store. There's an other
way around this. But the best way is actually
to use a Python in case you don't want to use
something that is being consumed special logic, I
use q Python. So Q Python is also is also a Python
literal, you can see this. So that's everything
you actually need. The same way the Pedro treats
and this is just, it has less space. Bob hydrator
is more more advanced and needs. Alright,
so basically, that is all for this tutorial,
and even need more of our code on phone. Please
don't forget to just comment down below, and I'll
be able to look it up for you emulate me to be
able to do up using using Django using Laravel
is a Code Igniter for or your phone or even need
a front end. doesn't tie with CSS. Yeah. Which we
will do. The CDN says the node is not working.
The time works. No, you should use the CDN. So
just comment down below and we'll see what we're
doing sweet. Alright, see you next time. Peace.